j'avais un v2 clicquot ça vous laisse de
la marge et vous découpez l'apprend
positionne la la partie plate les élèves
de cette classe de seconde bac pro sont
en plein exercice pratique et ce qu'ils
construisent depuis le début de l'année
c'est un avion entre 4 et 6 heures par
semaine il assemble les morceaux de 7
ans jean en kit
depuis qu'il a commencé la construction
alexandre rêve de pouvoir voler et quand
on lui demande s'il s'imagine un jour
piloter cet avion là bas des fois on l'a
peu à côté
on a percé des trous naples à côté donc
cran après on s'imagine faire des trous
à côté tout le temps et ensuite conduire
de le piloter c'est un peu un peu
stressant mais au final comme le prof
est tout le temps là pour nous toujours
nous encadrer vers feeling ce qu'on fait
ça là c'est confiant vote
les lycéens ont jusqu'à la terminale
pour achever le biplace fin 2015 il sera
restitué ensuite à la fédération
d'aviation qui a financé totalement les
éléments de l'appareil prête à monter le
tout pour une valeur de 20 mille euros
ce sont les professeurs qui sont à
l'origine de cette initiative
on a pris un petit peu sur le tas donc
on va commencer sur les cours de base et
apprendre à attaquer directement
directement sur la lune en seconde et mu
dont toute la partie on veut dire
mécanique montage démontage on peut
retrouver des compétences dans le
montage de la nuit la lecture de plans
les décisions autonomes x c'est aussi
une manière de s'ouvrir à un secteur qui
recrute l'aéronautique
le lycée louis blériot est le premier
établissement de france à se lancer dans
la construction d'un avion
c'est vraiment une fierté et puis
surtout pour ces jeunes là je pense que
c'est un projet assez unique
de pouvoir découvrir ce cet outil ce
cadeau qui leur a offert vraiment on a
des élèves qui est un petit peu timorés
au début qui maintenant bien pris la
mesure des choses qui se lance
pleinement dans la réalisation de ses
terres de cet ouvrage
l'expérience devrait être reconduite
avec la prochaine classe de seconde à
trappes
mais elle pourrait aussi voir le jour
dans d'autres lycées en france